K
AT THE WHITE HOUSE EARLY THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> Dana: THANK YOU FOR THE
UPDATE.
>> Bill: KARL ROVE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
GO BACK TO THE INTERVIEW.
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN PORTLAND,
OREGON OVER THE WEEKEND.
3 1/2 WEEKS AWAY FROM THE
ELECTION IN PORTLAND, OREGON.
>> OUR ECONOMY IS STRONG AS
HELL, HE SAID.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THINK.
THIS IS GUY WHO SAID INFLATION
WOULD BE TRANSITORY.
NOW HE IS TELLING US THAT OUR
ECONOMY IS STRONG AS HELL.
HE DID SO TWO DAYS AFTER THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS SAID
THE INFLATION RATE WAS 8.2% AND
CORE INFLATION RATE THAT TAKES
OUT THE THINGS THAT ARE MORE
VARIABLE HIT A 40-YEAR HIGH.
SO TWO DAYS BEFORE HE SAID OUR
ECONOMY IS STRONG AS HELL THOSE
NUMBERS CAME OUT.
IT IS ONE DAY AFTER THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" QUARTERLY SURVEY
OF ECONOMISTS FOUND THAT 63% OF
THE ECONOMISTS THINK WE'LL NOW
BE IN RECESSION WITHIN 12 MONTHS
WITH INTENDED JOB LOSSES.
AND THE PRESIDENT SEEMS
DISCONNECTED TO THE THING THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT WHEN THEY SIT DOWN AND TRY
TO PAY THEIR MONTHLY BILLS, WHEN
THEY GO TO THE STORE, FILL UP
THE CAR, WHEN THEY HEAR THE TALK
AT THEIR PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT
ABOUT A SLOWING ECONOMY AND
ABOUT HOW THE COMPANY IS EITHER
NOT HIRING OR IS MAYBE EVEN
THINKING ABOUT CUTTING BACK ON
EMPLOYMENT.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS OUT OF
TOUCH.
THAT'S THE THING THAT IS WORST
FROM A POLITICAL PERSPECTIVE FOR
ANYBODY WORRIED ABOUT QEMM
DEMOCRATIC CHANCES IN THIS
ELECTION LOOKING LIKE THEY DON'T
GET IT.
HE DIDN'T GET INFLATION LAST
YEAR.
>> Dana: ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS WERE OUT YESTERDAY
TRYING TO SPIN THIS.
LET'S LISTEN TO CALL FOR NUMBER
ONE.
>> DEMOCRATS SHOULD TALK ABOUT
THE ECONOMY.
>> IF WE HADN'T RESCUED THE
ECONOMY THROUGH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN WE WOULD BE FACED
WITH THE KINDS OF PROBLEMS.
ECONOMY AT RISK OF FREE FALL.
RETAIL SALES, PAYROLL
EMPLOYMENT, CONSUMER SPENDING,
INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTION, ALL OF
THOSE ARE NOT IN RECESSIONARY
TERRITORY.
>> Dana: HOW ARE THEY DOING?
>> BERNIE SANDERS INTERESTING
ABOUT THAT.
THIS WAS A CHALLENGE TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BASICALLY
SAYING STOP TALKING ABOUT
ABORTION SO MUCH AND START
TALKING ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
THE ECONOMY IS WHAT IS WORRYING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ADMINISTRATION HAD TO PUT
EVERYBODY OUT ON THE SHOWS THIS
WEEKEND IN ORDER TO CLAIM THAT
EVERYTHING IS OKAY, ECONOMY IS
DOING GREAT.
IF WE HADN'T DONE WHAT WE HAD
DONE WE WOULD BE IN WORSE SHAPE
BECAUSE OF THE INFLATION NUMBER
LAST WEEK.
INFLATION NUMBER WAS EXPECTED TO
BE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS.
THE INTERNALS GOT STRONGER, THE
CORE INFLATION RATE THAT HIT A
40-YEAR HIGH.
NICE SENDING OUT ALL THOSE
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONCLUDING THAT'S THE CROWD
RESPONSIBLE FOR SPENDING $5
TRILLION THAT INCREASED DEMAND,
INFLATION IS TOO MUCH MONEY
CHASING TOO FEW GOODS AND THAT
IS THE CROWD THAT PUT TOO MUCH
MONEY INTO THE SYSTEM AND
CONTINUES TO DO SO.
WE LEARNED THE COST OF PART OF
THEIR GIVEAWAY ON STUDENT LOAN
PROGRAM IS A HALF TRILLION.
WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
THE WHITE HOUSE SENT IT OUT AS
PEOPLE TO TELL REPORTERS WE
THINK IT WILL HAVE A GOOD IMPACT
ON GENERATING HIGHER TURNOUT
AMONG YOUNGER DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
THEY TOOK A HALF TRILLION
DOLLARS OF OUR MONEY, BORROWED
IT, PUT IT ON THE CHECK FOR OUR
KIDS AND GRANDKIDS TO PAY, IN
ORDER TO GET PEOPLE TO TURN OUT
TO VOTE THIS FALL.
THAT IS REALLY AMAZING.
>> Bill: ONE LAST THING HERE WE
TALKED ABOUT THE FOX POLL.
"NEW YORK TIMES" DID A POLL.
THIS IS THE MOST REVEALING
FINDING THERE.
INDEPENDENT WOMEN VOTERS LAST
MONTH FAVORED DEMOCRATS BY 14
POINTS.
NOW THAT SAME GROUP INDEPENDENT
FEMALE VOTERS BACK REPUBLICANS
BY 18 POINTS.
THAT'S A 30-POINT SWING.
>> REMEMBER, WE TALK ABOUT
RELATIVELY SMALL SAMPLE SIZES.
SOME OF THAT MAY BE THAT YOU'VE
GOT SORT OF MARGIN OF ERROR IS
VERY HIGH FOR THESE KIND OF
THINGS.
WHAT IT SHOWS IS MOVEMENT.
MOVEMENT -- WE'RE SEEING
MOVEMENT ACROSS THE BOARD.
CNN -- "THE NEW YORK TIMES" POLL
SHOWED THAT THE GENERIC BALLOT
IS MOVING IN THE REPUBLICAN WAY.
IT FLIPPED.
IT WAS ONE POINT UP BY
DEMOCRATS.
NOW FIVE POINTS UP BY
REPUBLICANS.
WE SEE THIS IN LOTS OF POLLS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM AS WE GET
CLOSER TO THE ELECTION AND MORE
POLLS USE SAMPLES OF LIKELY
VOTERS AS OPPOSED TO ALL VOTERS
OR ALL ADULTS.
REPUBLICANS ARE LOOKING STRONGER
AND STRONGER.
>> Bill: THE SHIFT IS ON IF YOU
ASK ME.
WE'RE SEEING IT, RIGHT?
>> AND REMEMBER THIS, REMEMBER
THIS IMPORTANT, THIS IS MY GREAT
-- THIS IS THE NUMBER I'M
LOOKING AT.
GALLUP SAID WHICH PARTY WOULD DO
A BETTER JOB OF HANDLING THE
PROBLEM YOU THINK IS MOST
IMPORTANT.
48R, 37D.
THE SECOND LARGEST ADVANTAGE FOR
THE REPUBLICANS SINCE THIS
QUESTION BEGAN TO BE ASKED IN
THE 1940s.
1946 AND REPUBLICANS HAD A
17-POINT ADVANTAGE.
TODAY 11.
THAT'S A BIG SIGN